- So, as we saw earlier,
when we were talking about "Timeless",
Leslie and I are obsessed with many,
many things in pop culture
and the internet knows this.
So, it's time to have an
honest conversation about.
♪ Obsessions ♪
(slow music)
And apparently...
- We're about to make a porno?
- We about to have porn.
(Kelly laughs)
- We're about to make porno, nice.
- That was amazing.
- Me and Kelly Clarkson
(Kelly laughs)
- Music was awesome, I love you guys.
Here's what we'll do,
I'll hit this button and
a topic will be selected,
by our super, random supercomputer.
- Okay.
- The person obsessed
with the topic will own up
and tell us about her
love of this obsession.
So, Leslie's obsessions are
up first, so here we go.
(ding) Here we go,
they're going to go there.
♪ Obsessions ♪
(slow music)
(Kelly laughs)
- Y'all set that up.
- [Kelly] Wait, wait.
(Kelly laughs)
- Y'all know I love Steve.
- So wait, what? What's happening here?
Look at you.
So why, why the obsession?
I mean, other than what's not to.
- Them damn khakis.
- The khakis.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
You like a man in khakis, oh my God.
- I like nerds.
- [Kelly] I do, I like nerds.
- I love nerds.
They are just so entertaining.
- [Kelly] Yeah and fun to be around.
- And he does the numbers.
(Leslie groans)
(audience and Kelly laugh)
When he pull that calculate out,
I was like, "What, you going
to tell me exact answer?"
(Kelly and audience laughs)
I love Steve.
Steve, count to ten.
- [Kelly] Count to ten
(Kelly and audience laughs)
While we're in those khakis.
- One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
I'm looking at your khakis, Steve.
- I feel like my obsession is not going
to be as great as hers.
(Leslie screams)
(Kelly laughs)
- And it ain't like he
got on a regular shirt,
like you ain't gonna get that in the mall.
You know what I'm saying?
You going to get that at like the GAP,
maybe, maybe, maybe, maybe,
maybe, that's the dressing.
I honestly think it's Ross, you know?
- Okay, hey.
- Because you can get like
four of them, in a pack.
- The next one is mine.
(ding)
♪ Obsessions ♪
(slow music)
Oh, speaking of, yes.
Okay, I Zillow porn.
Oh my gosh, SNL did a whole thing on this.
It was just so funny because...
- Oh, with me and the dude, right?
- No, I'm just saying, it's a real thing.
Like I will... I... Have you?
I have looked at places,
in random places all over the
world and all over the States
and I just find it so
interesting to find...
- Okay, that's like
watching HGTV, I feel you.
- I love... You look,
I love HGTV.
- HGTV is the bomb.
- Yes, yes.
- So, I could see that, I could see that.
- Yeah, oh my God, I will literally,
all of a sudden I'll
be like, "It's 1:00 AM,
like you need to stop".
- Yeah, but I guess it is porn
if you watch more than an hour, right?
(audience and Kelly laugh)
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love you, wait.
Okay, here we go.
(ding)
This is yours.
♪ Obsessions ♪
(slow music)
(Leslie groans)
What's Gunpowder Milkshakes?
Ooh, it's a show.
- Let me explain something
to you about this movie,
if you want to see some bad-ass women...
- [Kelly] I do.
- Watch this movie.
Literally, I've already seen it twice.
Every fight scene in this
movie is off the chain.
- Oh, I'm excited, I love action.
- No, no, no, no, no.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
I'm trying to tell you the
last scene of this movie is...
- Wait, don't spoiler.
- Epic.
(audience laughs)
- Okay, okay.
(Leslie screams)
(Kelly laughs)
- And you know, I love
me some Angela Bassett.
You know, sis love got
to do it, you know, like.
(audience applauds)
- That whole cast looks amazing.
- And I'm going to shout-out
too, "Hi, hi, Carol".
That's our favorite line in that movie,
"Hi, hi, Carol".
(Leslie and Carol laugh)
- Okay next one's me, this ones me.
♪ Obsessions ♪
(slow music)
Oh.
- You got some weird stuff, cuz.
- No, no.
(audience laughs)
No, you judge me, you judge me.
Don't you shame me.
- What the hell is top golf?
- Well, you know what?
You're going to love it,
you're going to love it.
No, it's a party vibe.
They got like a bar, they
got really, great bar food,
they got music playing.
They got... It's not like normal golf.
I suck at golf unless I'm
just driving the cart,
drinking, having a good time.
- Not like normal golf?
- It's not.
(audience laughs)
- That only comes out of a white person.
- [Kelly] No, it's not, no.
- First of all, don't nobody
know what regular golf is, so.
(Kelly laughs)
- No, I'm saying it's not like,
I don't like normal golf.
- But why's it top golf, do you top off?
- [Kelly] Because it's a game.
- Oh.
- [Kelly] No, it's a game.
So like, you know how they
have like, driving ranges
and they have like
levels, you see in movies.
I've never been to one, I
just mean in like, movies.
But like, you get up on
whatever level you're on
and you aim for these
different... It's a game.
You try and aim your ball
and knock your ball into
these like big, huge circles.
It sounds lame, how I'm describing it,
but it's not, it's not.
- It don't sound lame, it sound white.
- [Kelly] No, no, no.
(audience laughs)
Fun, white people...
No, but what I'm saying
is you're going with me, now.
- [Leslie] Fun, white
people, that's hilarious.
No, you look at me, now you are going.
- Only if I get to hit
people with the club.
That's the only reason
I'm going to go because...
- Well, bring someone you
want to hit with the club.
(Kelly and Leslie laugh)
- Come here.
- [Kelly] Because you can't hit me.
- This is not fun.
- No, I'm telling you, it's fun.
There's like, music going,
it's like a party vibe.
- Just because music is
going, Kelly, it's fun?
Ain't they got alcohol?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You could come to my house.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] I'm telling you.
- I got music and alcohol.
- And you're competitive, you'd love it.
- Okay, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- And here's the challenge,
you won't beat me.
- Okay.
- [Kelly] You know what?
We're going and you're going to love...
- And then I'm going to beat you
and then I'm going to
come back and be like,
"Y'all remember how Kelly was like,
popping off about her little, top golf".
(audience laughs)
- Yeah.
- She didn't even... She sobbed in there,
with a whole other song.
♪ Let me be at the top golf. ♪
(Kelly and Leslie laugh)
- [Kelly] I'm going to kick your ass now.